слуги народу оплесками проводжають Тепер
уже колишнього міністра оборони Олексія
резнікова після того як проголосували за
його відставку
уже Наступного дня Рада призначає нового
очільника Міноборони ним став Рустем
Умеров який до цього очолював Фонд
держмайна чому кадрові зміни
відбуваються Саме зараз і чого чекати
від нового керівника оборонного
відомства
Олексій резніков чимало зробив для
забезпечення ЗСУ західним озброєнням
Утім як визнають експерти у самому
міністерстві назрівали проблеми спершу
скандали з закупівлею продуктів для
військових за завищеними цінами за
півроку ще один так званий курточний
скандал
можливими якраз через те що пан резніков
був фокусований в основному на
міжнародну роботу на
міжнародний аспекти надання допомоги
збройним силам України і сама внутрішня
організація Міністерство як системи
можливо була не до кінця контрольована і
це
встановлювали такі такі можливості для
цих скандалів за словами політолога
Володимира фесенка заміну Олексію
резнікову не вдавалося знайти понад
півроку
більшість кандидатів відмовлялися йти на
цю посаду оскільки дуже велику увага
зараз до цього Міністерства це знаєте як
хтось пожартував що як електричний
стілець Тобто ти відразу потрапляєш під
що називається прожектори
оці надмірної уваги під критику
журналістське розслідування і так далі
не надто публічного росте маумерова
експерти називають ефективним менеджером
і переговорником Він навчався на заході
працював в інвестиційному бізнесі став
народним депутатом від партії голос
після початку повномасштабного
вторгнення був у складі української
делегації на перемовинах з Росією а
також займався адвокацією поставок
західної зброї
достатньо
досвіду в управлінні складними командами
як і всередині
державних органів так і всередині
бізнес-структури яка в Україні так і за
кордоном він також розуміється добре на
збройних питаннях
входить до складу
тимчасової слідчої комісії яка
слідкувала за тим куди йде міжнародна
збройна допомога Тобто це людина не з
вулиці вона розуміється б питання і
безпеки крім того росте Умеров етнічний
Кримський татарин і мусульманин
міжнародні ЗМІ зазначають його
призначення може бути сигналом про те що
Україна не поступиться Кримом його
турецькі зв'язки
кажуть що він має прямий доступ до офісу
редагана
і навіть один з небагатьох українських
керівників які має
можливість напряму спілкуватися за
вдоганом це обумовило його участі в
переговорах в березні минулого року але
також в переговорах по зерновій угоді в
переговорах про обмін полоненими зокрема
по обміну азовців
наведення ладу з контрактами на зброю у
системі закупівель боротьба зі
зловживаннями цифровізація армії належне
забезпечення війська те чого очікують
від нового міністра оборони що мені
здається важливо для нового міністра
було б це все ж таки добитися синергії в
роботі трьох міністерств Міністерства
оборони Міністерства стратегічної
промисловості і Міністерства це трьох
цифрової трансформації тут має бути
синергія тобто більше має бути лідерства
і як мені здається лідерство саме
Міністерство оборони за рік робота на
посаді очільника фонду держмайна
паномеров
как-то уникнув скандалів конфліктів якщо
Він навів лад достатньо проблемні
структури як Фонд держмайна то можливо
він зможе навести лати Міноборони Бо це
буде насправді його головна місія
очільниця центру протидії корупції Дарія
Калинюк звертає увагу на необхідність
масштабних кадрових чисток у Міноборони
а також на те що новому очільнику
відомства варто довести свою
незалежність від керівника офісу
президента Андрія Єрмака адже такі
закиди на його адресу вже є я буду
судити наскільки є людиною Ярмака по
його кадровим призначенням а особливо
його рішенням стосовно
заступника міністра оборони Шарапова
шараповця екс-бізнес-партнер Ярмака який
зараз координує всі оборонні закупівлі
збройні і незровні і
несе відповідальність за провал цей
закупівель разом з міністром резюками
тому
побачимо наскільки навіть за бажання у
міра вас змінити таких такого одіозну
постать як Шарапов наскільки йому це
дозволить президент та наш
віце-президентство де-факто Андрія Ярмак
Міністерство оборони є найбільшим
розпорядником коштів в Україні поки
триває війна тож увага до цього
відомства залишатиметься надзвичайно
прискіпливою